John Solomon investigative reporter
Sarah Carter Fox News legal analyst
Gregg Jarrett is with us John let's
start with your story we have so much
ground to cover this is pretty this is
massive this distinction is massive give
us what you got yeah I think you just
think back if in June of last year in
July of last year the FBI director had
accused her being grossly negligent what
impact that would have had on the
election what impact it would have had
on the legal debate about what we
thought the FBI knew we thought they
thought she was careless now we find out
she was grossly negligent that was the
term that was in the statute and it is
surprising that it got edited out and
the questions for Congress are going to
be who did they talk to before they
edited out who recommended editing it
out and why did they do it and I think
we're gonna get those answers in the
next couple of weeks all right let me go
to Gregg Jarrett legal analyst okay when
Comey deletes the specific legal term
gross negligence and it decides before
he does the investigation concludes he's
gonna exonerate her right this is being
done before he ever interviews her or
the other witnesses I've never heard of
it that's called the fixes in oh yeah I
mean I've been a lawyer for 37 years
I've never heard of a prosecutor
exonerating somebody two months in
advance before interviewing her and the
key witnesses when you cross out gross
negligence and insert extremely careless
that's pretty incriminating evidence
that Comey wore others may have been
obstructing justice they were trying to
interfere with the due administration of
justice and they were stupid in the way
they did it because gross negligence is
extremely careless behavior in fact when
jurors struggle with that the judge
gives them a standard jury instruction
here's California's for example gross
negligence is an extreme departure from
ordinary care in other words extremely
careless behavior so it tells me Comey
in addition to attempting to obstruct
justice perhaps doesn't know a damn
thing about the law scary but no when
the fix is in its corruption when the
fix when you don't when you have a
conclusion before an investigation the
fix was in okay let me go through this a
little bit with Sarah Carter so she
steals she rigs the the primary election
and Democrats are trying to tell us all
that's not a big
and she tried to fix the general
election by paying for Russian bought
and paid propaganda lying about Donald
Trump and then we have it gets even
bigger than that then we've got you know
the fix would call me as we were just
talking about then the fix with Loretta
Lynch on the tarmac is there anything
the Clintons don't fix or try to fix
well over the last year you know the
Democrats have been pointing their
finger at the Trump campaign you know
and at President Trump that he had to
fix in with Russia but all the evidence
Sean points to the Democrats and Russia
and this is beyond partisan because what
John showed in this story with this
removal of gross negligence was
something that the FBI
I mean agents within the FBI since last
July when Comey made this statement they
were up in arms people within the FBI
former FBI agents they were so
frustrated they didn't understand what
was going on here
one thing they did understand was that
there was some kind of fix and they
wanted to figure out why did Comey do
this and now we see there's a little bit
more evidence shedding light onto this
all right John let's go back to your
reporting let's go back to what you have
you actually updated your column from
earlier today why don't we give
everybody the latest news yeah it wasn't
just a single time but they mentioned
this
tournament they went in those negligence
gross negligence that they were in and
they said listen one of the things that
strikes us is there were lots of secret
information that passed through that
pattern that they use that comment
constant being able to put that into the
emails really concerned them as evidence
of what was going on here and I think it
wasn't an accidental term that was
thrown in there it was thought through
early on in May and by June somehow that
term drops out of the statement it's
very surprising and I think people can
ask a lot of questions what about the
whole email issue right that we're now
understanding more I mean if I deleted
33,000 emails right if I destroyed my
hard drives if I busted up my
BlackBerry's what would happen would I
be calling you from jail you'd be
charged with obstruction of justice a
violation of the federal Records Act and
the public officers law those are three
criminal statutes that have serious
penalties
when you receive a congressional
subpoena on your documents you are
instructed to preserve and produce them
she chose neither one of them she's
annoyed 37,000 of them and it is
inconceivable to me that she wasn't
charged
let me the last question I've got to
update the audience Sarah on uranium 1
now every day every week this keeps
growing as well the fact that Comey I'm
sorry that Muller and Eric Holder knew
about bribery extortion kickbacks money
laundering racketeering in oh nine how
do they get to investing how does Muller
investigate anything Russia shouldn't he
be investigated shouldn't everyone
involved in that deal be investigated I
certainly know from talking to sources
Sean I don't think it's going to be
Muller and I don't think it's going to
be Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein and I know now that Attorney
General Jeff Sessions did not recuse
himself from the uranium 1 investigation
it is huge it is huge and it's you know
despite the fact that we've seen reports
out there that they said he did he did
not so I believe right now there is an
ongoing investigation into this I do
believe that a special counsel will be
announced we're not certain yet but this
is where the direction it's going in and
we just have to remain patient and wait
and see all right you guys have done
amazing work we're like on peeling the
layers of an onion and here's what I can
tell everybody in the media that's so
lame
tick-tock there's so much more coming